[Applause]
familiar territory for Jeremy Corbyn
back to the place he grew up and where
he feels at home the campaign trail I
think it is time for real change and I
can't wait for December the 12th but are
the public ready for him you say that
this election isn't about you that it is
about the labor movement but do you
worry that your personal poll ratings
could become a block on Labour's path to
victory
I don't particularly follow poll ratings
all I know is in a 2017 election there
were queues of them experts in TV
studios and radio studios and so on
lining up at the beginning of the
campaign to write off the Labour Party
they didn't win the election but labour
won the campaign this time around they
hope to win both hi Jeremy Corbyn nice
to see you on the trail you glad to get
going love to vote leave tell furred
with a Tory majority of to 720 is a must
get but will missed kuban's brexit plan
to have another referendum next year put
voters here off not this one
what P is doing is fantastic that's the
thing you would you're happy to have a
people's vote a second referendum next
year if it is there this offend us
together because the buster is been
driven by false promises but mr corbyn's
promise of a new dean and a referendum
could be washed away if the EU refused
to agree a fourth brexit extension what
are you gonna do if the EU don't grant
you that extension I am very clear that
an incoming government will get the time
necessary to negotiate will get that
extension and indeed I've discussed you
know well I've discussed this with
Kirsten with many officials in the EU
and heads of governments rustic Barnaby
yes so it's Michelle
really matters that it's about is an
incoming government after a general
election must be given the time in order
to negotiate it yesterday
Janka said he doesn't think yours is a
realistic approach he doesn't think you
can count on that extension so the
reason I'm asking is that people can
have to vote for you blind not knowing
if you want to leave or stay and you
might have to take that decision at the
end of January one thing is very very
clear we're not going into a no deal
exit I think we will get the deal we
need to get and you have spoken to
macron and Marco because you said you
spoke with Helen kept in touch with
Hamas's he spoken to the EU and he
spoken to these people - they might be
sold on him but he'll have to sign up
millions more in the coming weeks to win
bath Rigby Sky News